it was billed as a box office pmqs a
moment of political Peril for a PM
defending a cabinet minister Under Fire
but instead the hall fell silent as a
labor leader opened with a question
about the murder of Zara Alina
opportunities were missed by the
probation service that could have
prevented this attack and saved her life
does the Prime Minister accept those
findings
Mr Speaker this was a truly terrible
crime
and as the Chief Inspector has found the
failings in this case and indeed others
were serious and indeed unacceptable
but it was a pmqs of two halves the mood
turned and the noise in the chamber
returned as a labor leader moved to
Nadim zahawi's tax affairs
does the Prime Minister agree
that any politician who seeks to avoid
the taxes they owe in this country is
not fit to be in charge of taxpayer
money
well Mr Speaker I'm pleased to make my
position on this matter completely clear
to the house
[Applause]
what was really interesting was a
contrast with last week where the PM
tried to brush a controversy aside my
honorable friend has already addressed
this matter in full and there's nothing
more that I can add Rishi sunak
defending Nadim zahawi but listen to him
this week the issues in question
occurred before I was prime minister
with regard to the appointment of the
minister without portfolio the usual
appointments process was followed no
issues no issues were raised with me
no defense whatsoever for his cabinet
colleague this week instead Rishi sunak
effectively said he's not to blame for
whatever happens next what kistama wants
to do is make this not just about Nadeem
zahawi but Rishi sunak himself the labor
leader again pushed the attack that the
PM is weak his failure to sack him when
the whole country could see what's going
on shows how hopelessly weak he is
is he starting to wonder if this job is
just too big for him
[Applause]
and Rishi sunak also fell back onto Old
attack lines with yet another reference
to kierstama's predecessor when I
disagree fundamentally with the previous
prime minister I resigned from the
government but before but for four but
for four long years he sat next to the
member for Islington North
and as the front benches became more
animated I know he reads from these
prepared sheets but he should listen to
what I actually said
look at Labor here accusing the PM of
not reading his own notes then came
another personal swipe from the smp's
Stephen Flynn what advice would he have
for individuals seeking to protect their
personal finances should they seek out
our future chair of the BBC to help
secure and 800 000 pounds loan
should they set up a trust in Gibraltar
and hope that hmrc simply don't notice
or should they do as others have done
and simply apply for non-dorm status
[Music]
there were familiar insults but no real
killer blow on a day like today the PM's
team will be pleased that more damage
wasn't inflicted and hope that some of
the heat in The zahari Rao may have
passed for now